ده رئيس هيئه الدفاع عن القضاه المعزولين
المحامي كمال بن مسعود فوز فرانكات انه
تمت احاله 13 قاضيا من بين القضاه
المعزولين بموجب مرسوم رئه حالتهم الى
القطب القضائي لمكافحه الارهاب بشبهات
التامر على امن الدوله من المقرر ان ينظر
ان المجلس الاعلى للقضاء يوم 24 من يناير
المقبل في مطالب برفع الحصانه عن من عدمه
عن 13 قاضيا احيل اذا على القطب القضائي
لمكافحه الارهاب ومطالب رفع الحصانه جاءت
بطلب من قضاه التحقيق
بعد الان تونس العاصمه مراسل فونس 24 نور
الدين مباركي اهلا بك نوردين نتوقف معك
عند حيثيات هذه القضيه قضاه اذا كانوا
معزولين وحيل الى القطب القضائي لمكافحه
الارهاب حيثيات هذه القضيه
فانا القطب القضائي فان المجلس الاعلى
توصل بطلب من القضاه التحقيق من القطب
القضائي لمكافحه الارهاب لرفع الحصانه عن
ثلاث 10 وذلك لاستنطاقهم على خلفيه وهم او
شبهه وهم وجهه اليهم تتعلق بالتامر على
امن الدوله الداخلي وايضا تتعلق بتكوين
وفاق اجرامي المتوقع ان يجتنعه همم
المجلس الاعلى المؤقت القضاء يوم 24 جانفي
المقبل لان النظر في هذه المطالب هذا
الملف ودادي
عندما قرر الرئيس سعيد بموجب مرسوم عزه
النحو سبعه في القادريا وذلك على خلفيه
شبهات فساد وايضا شبهات طاطا في قضايا
ارهابيه هذا القرار الذي لم يقبله
العديد من الحركات جي ثم التلجؤه في نهايه
الامر الى المحكمه الاداريه التي قررت
ايقافه تنفيذ 49 قاضيا بمعنى انه بضروط ان
يعودوا الى عملهم لكن وزاره العدل قالت ان
هؤلاء القضاه هم زالوا الى حدود هذه
اللحظه وموضوع قضايا منشوره لدى القضاء
وهذه القضايا تتعلق بقضايا فساد وتتعلق
ايضا بقضايا ارهاب والمتعلق بالقضايا
الارهاب المقصود بها هو التواضع في قضايا
الارهابيه وايضا عدم الكشف عن بعض الملفات
ومن المتوقع ان يتم في ذلك خلال شهر جانفي
الفارق نعم نعم المقبل